o cómo está la situación de orden
público actualmente en la ciudad de lima
tras el anuncio de la retirada
y muy buenas tardes estimado rodrigo es
un gusto poder estar con ustedes en
estos momentos de mensaje nosotros
estamos conversando todavía hay un muy
importante grupo de ciudadanos
protestando frente a lo que es el
congreso y están tratando de llegar a lo
que es la plaza mayor el lugar donde
están la residencia y en las oficinas
del presidente de la república porque
esto porque hay una sensación de que el
presidente castillo no gobierna y que ha
defraudado a la población es un
presidente que en el término de ocho
meses ha tenido más de 50 ministros dos
tentativas de vacancia por parte del
congreso imputaciones a sus familiares
cercanos como son sus sobrinos de que
están en actos de corrupción un
secretario general de palacio de
gobierno a quien se le encontró 20 mil
dólares que no tenían explicación en un
baño de palacio de gobierno y en fin una
serie de hechos que han sido
negativos en estos 8 meses pero todos
estos hechos también se ven agravados en
los últimos días por cuanto han habido
una serie de protestas por la subida de
los combustibles por la subida de los
alimentos y que el gobierno no ha sabido
manejar este es el resultado de un
desgobierno y este es el resultado
también de medidas impopulares como las
tomadas anoche que inconstitucionalmente
y sin ninguna racionalidad
establecieron este toque de queda o esta
orden de inamovilidad para el día de hoy
para
aliviar la presión el presidente
castillo lo que ha hecho es ha generado
verbalmente una manifestación que dice
que va a quitar en la orden de
inamovilidad con otro decreto supremo
pero sabemos que una norma recién entra
en vigencia al día siguiente su
publicación entonces estando aumentada
en vigencia mañana va a ser ya no tenía
sentido este toque que sí señor muñoz
sin usted nos ha hablado de las
protestas de los últimos días pero
durante estas protestas han ofrecido su
colaboración
o han mantenido contacto con el
presidente castillo
sí muchas veces hemos ofrecido a
nosotros colaboración hemos querido que
se enmienden en los errores del gabinete
y del ejecutivo en general pero siempre
encontramos buena voluntad en la
recepción pero oídos sordos en la
ejecución de estas estas propuestas de
colaboración que se han planteado
pero el presidente castillo sin embargo
ha dicho hoy en el congreso que esta
medida no era contra el pueblo y que la
retirada es un símbolo de predisposición
al diálogo con el legislativo es posible
que ahora sí que se dé este diálogo que
no ha llegado hasta ahora en perú que
como usted bien ha dicho lleva durante
los últimos meses con varias crisis
dentro del gobierno
quisiéramos que fuese así rodrigo pero
vemos que el presidente vive como en un
mundo paralelo en un mundo que no está
sintiendo lo que pasa en las calles que
no siente también el clamor que hay de
los ciudadanos que a su vez sienten que
en el bolsillo les está pegando una
economía que cada vez es más dura y que
no les alcanza para los consumos básicos
de la canasta familiar entonces mientras
que uno esté alejado de la realidad
cualquier decisión que tomen no va a ser
una decisión importante de
gobernabilidad
y desde la alcaldía se ha hecho algún
tipo de medida se ha tomado algún tipo
de medida para que esta crisis para que
esta protesta llegue a su fin para poder
ayudar a los camiones
nosotros tenemos una serie de programas
que son programas que permiten la
distribución de alimentos a precios de
mayorista en distintos puntos de la
ciudad el no controlamos nosotros porque
no es parte de nuestras facultades lo
que es el control de las carreteras eso
le corresponde al ministerio de
transportes y comunicaciones ya la
policía nacional pero de alguna manera
para paliar esta crisis hemos estado
llevando mercados móviles a distintas
partes de la capital porque en los
últimos días ha subido intensamente en
los precios de cada uno de los productos
de panllevar o productos de primera
necesidad